this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house it's Monday the 30th of January
the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings listen NBA fans it's time to
bring the heat with DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
part of the NBA this week new customers
just bet five dollars and I'm Gonna Get
You
203 bets instantly and he picks for
myself for this week I got nothing every
day go on there DraftKings is going to
have a no sweat same game parlay Plus
for a limited time go to DraftKings
Sportsbook app today opt-in and place
the same game ballet on an NBA game if
it doesn't hit you'll get a free BET
where else do you get that DraftKings
download the app now I'll sign up with
code Joey j-o-e-y new customers can bet
five dollars on any NBA and get 200 and
free bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the NBA with code Joey minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details the joint is
also brought to you by the freeze pipe
if you're tired of [__] harsh smoke
and coughing attacks every time you rip
it's time for the icy freeze pipe just
freeze it pack it and rip that
[__] the smoke passes through
the Frozen part tremendous it cools the
smoke down as you inhale it you don't
even feel it going in I love freeze pipe
I got the bubbler I got the bung I
alternate between the both of them and
they are tremendous freeze pipe is
non-toxic and freezes faster than water
and stays Frozen longer freeze pipe
cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees now freeze pipe is even better
the 2023 Edition they've updated their
bunks so you have six independent
freezing calls for even better airflow
and much easier cleaning experience your
Uncle Joe is taking care of you on this
one go to thefreeze pipe.com pressing
code Diaz Diaz to save 10 on your first
order get yourself a new bong pipe a
bubbler today that's the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Diaz d i a z to save 10
let's get this [__] party
started it's Monday morning
foreign
[Music]
[__] welcome to another episode
Uncle Joey's joint Monday the 30th of
January it's over it was just the
holidays you were just singing [__]
happy birthday happy Merry Christmas
jumping up and down
[__] having a good time for New
Year's I thought by now it was like the
10th that's what it feels like to me
Christmas feels like it was 10 [__]
days ago and we're already talking about
February [__] first on
Wednesday but anyway
it's a good month we finished it now we
got a whole new week with a whole new
set of rules we got a whole new month
rent is due on [__] Wednesday so
whatever no snow people are pissed off
that's not [__] snowing yet uh it's
not gonna snow in February I can't
believe how gullible people are listen
you're gonna get 100 inches
every [__] winter may not be now and
may not be later but it's coming I see
all these people already taking their
bikinis out and [__] roller skates
like oh it's going to be 50 this week
first off the weather's going to drop
again this [__] week and then
we're going into the February let me
tell you something growing up I would
look at those albums when I was a kid
and one thing that was always a constant
there was always snow on February 19th
on the floor
so for me I know it's coming but for
everybody else [__] them uh The
Residency ended last Saturday
and I got to tell you something it was
great it was a great experience
I'm happy it's over I learned a lot I
never done a residency before
and I didn't know what how it was going
to be Sony theater was great that [__] I
had a state that the other night it was
[__] great I was I didn't eat we left
in a [__] rush it was going to be
traffic Louis C.K was doing the garden
the Knicks were playing [__]
you know uh Brooklyn it was [__]
crazy and when I didn't even have a
chance to eat dinner when I got there I
go I got to eat something
the [__] stake was tremendous it was
like I was at a [__] Steakhouse at
least the price was like 28 dollars or
something like what the [__] Sony
theater is great and it was a great
venue
I just wished I did the shows a little
differently like I learned I don't know
what I want to do differently next time
I think I would do like a combo uh New
York Maybe
Philly or Jersey like once either or
once a month
um I don't know I think I would do more
lights
Maybe video I don't know I don't know
the DJ worked but not really kind of
sort of like it was okay I expected
something else from a DJ I didn't know I
just saw what they do on these [__]
big concerts and [__]
so I learned a lot
um
I wish I would have worked at it a lot
more
but like I said I'm swamped with every
other thing in my life every other facet
my life
you know uh
this week was [__] weird like I just
had a
a lot of people were doing things Friday
and for some reason or another my phone
didn't stop ringing
and it's like a friend of mine was
having a party at five [__] 30 in the
mouth of [__] hell like the mouth of
hell
and I like the guys like my nephew you
know
but my wife is working now uh
you know till about 4 35 every day she
goes in a little later she works out
whatever
and I just don't have the time that I
had he kept calling me about like hey
man we're gonna do this that's great
I know you're gonna like firecrackers
and shoot each other but I can't bring a
[__] 10 year old to a [__]
gangster party you know what I'm saying
like it's just not gonna work for her
and for you guys you know
another friend of mine from the podcast
that I haven't seen in like two years he
was having something at Sparks at 6 30
and [__] night
six o'clock at night at Sparks
you know what the chances of me [__]
getting there
like if you have any [__] idea and
I'm sitting there going like I feel bad
because I got to turn these people down
but obviously they don't listen to the
podcast no more they don't communicate
with me or they just don't want to
I don't know I don't know what to expect
from people anymore I just really don't
you know you know my situation and then
when I tell them I can't go they pull
[__] rank on me like they get mad at
me like what do you mean you gotta come
I I [__] can't for starters I'm an
hour away and it's Friday with traffic
for me to get the spark Steakhouse on a
[__] Friday
you know it's it's I have another friend
that calls me all the time like and
these aren't like people I grew up with
like I just know them really well
and they constantly like hey man do you
want to come when I look at the [__]
uh and this guy's like the master of
this [__] he always picks these
locations that are the farthest in the
world
like he hit me up Tuesday night at like
10 30 hey are you available tomorrow
morning to go an hour and a half from
your house to meet me and I'm like
no
what the [__]
and then he hits me up again Friday
night at three to ask me
if I could meet him and like [__]
Brooklyn or some [__] at some Russian
bar and I'm like
and you feel bad you feel terrible
because you can't do [__]
but then again it's like I've told these
[__] 20
000 times amen
I got a kid just give me a little
Advance you know just give me a little
well bring the kids let me tell you
something do you [__] think my
daughter wants to get in the car and
driving out is that what you [__]
think
I mean she's more against it than I am
my daughter hates getting that car
driving longer than 20 minutes she'll
tell you that is this necessary mom is
this not no it's not [__] what are we
doing this for turn this [__]
around you know she don't want to do she
when we lived in Los Angeles we lived
for seven years with her being the only
child
only child whenever I had a party
she'd be there if we went out to dinner
she'd be that with adults if we went to
a movie she'd be there we don't have we
didn't have what we have in in New
Jersey so now we made a [__] deal we
got here she's like listen I don't want
to be anywhere with this [__] adults
and yeah it's the truth
and sometimes neither do I you're right
Mike neither do [__] eye it's like
she doesn't you know I took her to a
wedding
and because again I felt guilty as a you
know as a friend you feel guilty
um don't have family down here I rotate
one babysitter amongst eight families
when you call this girl like I gotta
call her two months out and go hey man
are you available March 4th or whatever
and people it's like you tell them it
goes in one ear and it comes out to [__]
another I have never
in my life
been in the time period the last 10
years with a gift of listening has gone
out the window
it's gone out the [__] window
you know people will ask you a question
on Friday call you two hours later and
ask you the same [__] question and
you're like
I'm the [__] one I'm the one that's
got five listen
last night I was telling these guys I
got some weed from New York a friend of
mine gave me some New York weed
it is so [__] bad
and it was like 24 25 percent
Mike it was so bad it looked okay and I
put it away for a week and it just fell
apart after a week it just grew on its
own like it didn't even have a
connection didn't even have a dirt I
could see if somebody gave me a plant
and what pot kept growing it was just
muds and it kept growing and it kept
getting ugly and finally when I smelled
it
smelled like pure [__] dirt
so the other day some care now because
I'm at the suspensary it's better than
Joey I go listen
I'm not saying that my weed is the best
but it's anything better than I smoked
around [__] here
way better than anything that that's
grown around here it's just not working
for you [__] it's not you're
paying top dollar it smelled like
[__] dirt not even the point of this
story let me have a [__] point that's
what happens when you do a Bunga before
the [__]
for the podcast
you know it's like I want to call that
weed that we got autism because compared
to the [__] [__] yeah compared to
this [__] the people give me to try out
it's [__] autism weed I thought the
guys from laughing gas Saturday night I
go our next batch
anything over 36 percent is going to be
called autism because that's what this
weed gives you I had a friend almost
pass out here this week he puked twice
from doing two [__] bong hits and
you're gonna come tell me that you got
better [__] it's like people always
want to like pick a fight with you or
argue with you but the main thing is
it's like
the listening level in this country has
gone out the [__] window I remember
when podcasting started
I was very against the video you know
that right
because I was so pissed and Leo tell you
Leah concurred this with me
I realized that we had when I came up I
listened to albums growing up comedy
albums I listened to music albums I
[__] love albums because it exploits
the gift of hearing listening something
we don't do anymore I don't know what
the [__] happened
you know I see people walking around
with earpods you know they listen to
their own world it's it's the weirdest
thing so people are listening
it's just that [__] I don't know if
it comprehends you could tell somebody
something on a Tuesday and on Thursday
they'll repeat the same thing they did
wrong on a [__] Tuesday and then on
Saturday they'll do the same thing and
on Monday they'll do the same thing and
when you ask them they'll look at you
and go oh
I thought it was for that day no no no
it's for every [__] day
it's for every [__] day it's like
when you want to die you just don't eat
on days you want to eat and like today
I'm gonna go on a diet tomorrow I'm
gonna [__] eat milkshakes and
cheesecake pies whatever the [__] they
are
it's like people forget it's every day
when you get up every day
you pee
you wash your hands you throw water in
your face you brush your teeth that's
not what you just do on Monday it's
every [__] day
so as Lee when we started the podcast
our main goal was I wanted people to
listen you ever see a picture picture
from the 50s of a family what's a family
doing in the [__] 50s
they're not sitting there with iPods on
[__] three of them were [__] you
know now they're sitting around the
radio
not saying a word
listening
listening I got a hard time here at the
house I love my wife to death but during
the show she'll go on a [__] chatter
about something that's got nothing to do
with what's going on and she's passed it
on to my daughter see I play deaf
I played deaf I am deaf but I play Death
even better if there's ever an actor
that could play Death it's going to be
me I'm going to win the Academy Award
nobody plays Death better than me
I just sit there and stare right at that
TV and I don't [__] budge those two
[__] Knuckleheads my wife and my
daughter don't [__] you know and then
they'll one of them will say something
and they'll talk over a whole [__] 20
minute section of where the meat and
potatoes I just sit there and I don't
say nothing until about a week ago and I
had to say like guys that's it
I'm [__] really deaf now at this
point I'm really deaf me acting death is
just [__] now
so they'll sit there somebody will say
something and then they'll talk right
over it and I had to tell them listen no
talking
to the commercial any question you want
to ask ask during the commercial because
both these drive me [__] crazy to
both of you they don't know how to
[__] listen to both of them so now
we're only allowed to talk to her in the
commercials but I want you to work on
the gift of [__] listening guys
it'll make and I see people do it
constantly especially kids
watch kids
you know you say something hold on well
this is how you doing them Michael you
take the string no but that's what I was
doing
you didn't [__] listen to me [__]
sucking you didn't listen to me at all
you just jumped on me and guess who used
to do that I did that until about 15
[__] years ago
even a little longer 20 years I learned
that you have to [__] listen stand up
comedy is about [__] listening
when you're on stage
death as I've been for years from the
concerts and blowing smoke in my ear and
[__] putting the crack whatever the
[__] I did in my ears
think about when you're on stage how
precise your timing has to be
okay so I'm listening for that at all
[__] times
so what I'm trying to tell you is I
learned how to be deaf
but just to listen for what's important
do you follow what that is so when I'm
on stage and you're throwing [__]
heat on stage and you have to insert the
jokes in between their [__] when
they're breathing that takes years to
[__] develop that day she is and it
comes from listening so you listen to
that particular thing for years I was
having a hard time I have hearing aids
I wear them all the time until the
pandemic because they fly out not
because I'm basically deaf because for
years I would strain my ears listening
for the laughter
in between the chitty chat in between
the [__] idiot asking the way to what
the specials are you know what the
specials are Budweiser drink it that's
it we just went and thought gin and
tonic whatever the [__] it is but all
that [__] I had to just listen to you
people breathing
so I could I could anticipate the joke
think about what a [__] comedian does
this is what people don't [__] this
is what they tell you don't [__] talk
during the show
don't and this way to tell you to
protect you and the other people around
you when you go to the movie theaters
and you want to chit chat to your
[__] friend on the phone
listen just get up get the [__] out
get the [__] out I when I was when I was
a [__] civilian I'd go to the movies
for six [__] hours and sit there and
smoke dope all day guess what happens
when you become a [__] human being
people call you for work people [__]
work in the daytime
so I would go to the movie theaters for
years try to focus and then some [__]
agent text you and you're like God damn
it
and you're sitting there now the things
the call starts to eat away you're like
this is my livelihood I gotta answer
this [__] call you know so what do
you get up you and now you just defeated
the purpose you just defeated the whole
[__] movie now you had to step out
for six [__] minutes and go back in
my point is
I don't even know my point is my point
[__] is that
we just forgot to listen over the years
we just want to talk and we want to be
us and we want to [__] be stars and I
get it I [__] get it
but if you're not listening you're not
[__] living guys it's just not gonna
[__] work for you but over the years
with comedy I couldn't believe that when
I started not hearing things I asked
questions you know I had a doctor and I
called him one day a doctor friend in LA
and I called him and he connected me
with a guy that just worked with ears I
don't know what that [__] uh an ear
nose and throat doctor and we were
talking about the levels of death how
you go deeper and he was like well I
don't understand is how you're a
comedian and that's when it got
interesting the conversation because
he's like if you're not he goes I don't
believe that you're really deaf
because what do you do on stage and I'm
like oh [__]
this motherfucker's got a point here
so I started seeing that when I would be
at restaurants at night eating before I
got the hearing aids like let's say I
was having dinner with Mike Mike could
be telling me about his favorite band
about a basketball game about his
favorite guitar and I'll tell you what
even though Mike was looking at me I
could not hear [__] Mike even though
I'm reading his lips I would have to
stretch and read his lips and now I'm
getting [__] sick from [__]
straining my eyeballs
but I would hear in the restaurant even
though I was looking at Mike
I could hear Forks
I could hear the dishwasher in the back
like [__] throwing the forks in the
water I could see when he piled the
dishes up even though there were tables
all around me listening and I was
listening to them I couldn't hear that
conversation I could hear this [__]
farthest away from me so that's how we
figured out that I'm not really deaf I
needed [__] like nearsighted but yes
I I guys this is the most [__] up
thing it [__] me up for a long time I
was having a hard time with it but you
know
who gives a [__] I'm deaf all I'm saying
is guys listen if you really want to do
well in your life
you gotta listen
you know
when I do comedy I am not a prima donna
but I know by no you know well uh Mike
we're not doing the show there's white M
M's in the room you know you see the
Green Room at the New York you've seen
the other green moves when you come to
my show there's not flowers out and
[__] tons of food you know I don't
even when even the clubs have said to me
Joey
[__] uh the writer you know you
didn't put anything on your writer is
there anything you want I'm like water
you know and they'll go no alcohol and
I'm like you know what put 12 Beers in
that for my friends when they come down
after the show or whatever and they'll
go okay you know whatever
I don't
guys I don't uh
I mean we all get
we all can't wait for like you know we
all can't wait can you imagine [__]
tomorrow you're in a band mic and Guns
and Roses calls that band and go you're
going on tour with them
you know if this was 30 years ago you go
holy [__] I better go get a liquid IV in
me and some IV bottles because these
[__] Guns and Roses are going
to punish me with their with the alcohol
and the drug abuse and you know whatever
I'm not saying that they're junkies I'm
just saying that the [__] 80s 70s and
90s you know people [__] went out and
lost their mind not everybody's uh look
at these bands today you don't hear
anything about them they fall off stage
not even partying I don't go to bed
what's the guy that slight with the
shoes
I forget what this fight he's off he's
all tattooed up
post Malone didn't he fall off state
twice he ain't no Quaaludes you know
what I'm saying he ain't no Vicodins or
nothing like that this guy's falling off
they they don't you know they don't even
yeah they don't even [__] they don't
even need
I mean you know
when we were growing up these bands went
out and lost their [__] minds I mean
they [__] drank they put
women's [__] they [__] you know
did orgies you watch The Motley Crue
movie so when you anticipate going on a
[__] tour with somebody you're like
oh [__]
we can't wait to see what the [__]
Green Room is like
that's gonna be a party it's going to be
[__] Motley Crew and Def Leppard and
people going to be women are going to be
licking my balls and sniffing my farts
and I'm you know and then you
get there and it is what it is you know
and I understand that if I was the
opening act to [__] Guns and Roses
I'm throwing away my AAA card you know
what I'm saying there's no reason to
have an AA card or to have an NA sponsor
you're going down that's just the way it
is unless you're just gonna be a [__]
uh if you're just gonna be whatever the
[__] you call it you know I'm not going
to drink and after three months they're
gonna fire you anyway but that's not the
the situation here the situation uh
what is a green room what are the
expectations of a green room you know
when you
when you're a feature act an emcee and
you don't know any better you go into
the [__] Green Room thinking oh [__]
you know before the show we're gonna
[__] do this and shoot heroin and you
know and then you you get to the room
and the headline is when you walk in the
room the headline is reading a book
and you're like
am I in the right [__]
type of place you know am I in the and
and you learn from that headliner you're
like holy [__] I want in there to
[__] smoke pot I brought a bag of
mushrooms
my brother checked that
you know it's loose and all this [__]
and now this guy's reading a [__]
book
then you walk into another Green Room
and that guy is [__]
whatever losing his mind drinking
[__] you know when I was developing
was a big difference than when
I got to LA in 2000 well when I got to
L.A and started rocking and rolling like
2013. it was a different game room from
97 for me
to 2007 or 2011 when I was on the road
doing triple runs and just working on my
own
I wasn't the Captain Kirk of the [__]
Green Room
I was a guest in The Green Room there's
a lot of MCS and features today that'll
say to me hey man I gotta ask you a
question I worked with a comic last week
and wasn't the nicest guy in the world
but he didn't allow us in the in the
green room is that right and I go you
know what a headline I can do another
[__] he wants
you know maybe he's got people in there
maybe he's got a girl in there maybe
he's got something that he doesn't want
to see you do nobody's guaranteed in the
[__] Green Room I mean the headline
has got to be a real dick not to let you
in but you know what I [__] mean I
mean it's like
but people's expectations of the Green
Room are [__] crazy by the time I was
a feature act I knew that the Green Room
didn't mean anything to me because hey I
didn't drink and B I wasn't going to do
coke before the [__] show anyway
so you know what the [__] am I doing
this for
so after a while the Green Room just
became the Green Room you can't smoke
pot in the [__] Green Room unless you
get to that level then they'll [__]
let you go so you had to walk around the
corner to smoke a joint and that was the
end of it for me
and then I was on the road with Rogan
and that green room was a couple joints
we giggled we drank some water and we
basically laughed in that green room
there was no girls that was me Ari
Duncan Red Band Joe you know Tate it was
just a bunch of guys that would do Jiu
Jitsu in there they would bring in mats
and roll and take their shoes off you
know but meanwhile the people in the
audience like oh my God what's going on
back there we got to get back there
there's nothing going on back there
you're just going to be a [__] you're
just going to be a guy standing it's not
even fair you know that they're they're
in their own [__] world you know but
people would go back there and call me
like a week later and go that was
another eventful Green Room yeah what'd
you expect [__] circus diesel a what
the [__] did you expect
and then you know I started lying a
little bit I was featuring
I got off the road for a while and I'll
never forget going back on the road
after the church
and I was in Buffalo one day
some guy came up to me outside I think I
was working with Lee and Dean listen
I can't set the world on fire but Dean
and Lee definitely don't set the [__]
world down fine sweetheart of a guy in
fact I saw Dean the other night and it
was [__] really great to see him I
forgot how much I missed him
but we're not lighting the room on fire
you know some kid came up to me in
Buffalo I'm not kidding you he had 500
bills and he goes I want to give you 500
if I could sit in the green room with
you guys
for 10 minutes and it really like I was
like nah nah I'm not taking your money
if you want and after about three
minutes I go you know what I feel bad
for this guy I want to show him what a
green room is and I went out and I
caught his attention I caught his eye
and I'm like you know come over here
look at me and like what's up man come
here for a second I want to bring in the
dream was like really he was all excited
and we walked in there and it was Lee
writing a joke and Dean listening to his
[__] set from the night before and
I'm just sitting there and I go if you
want to hit that [__] half a joint
that's it there's a water in the
refrigerator and he was blown the [__]
away he's like where's the hose where's
the booze where's the bottles and I go
Doug I'm not gonna lie to you I don't
know what the [__] movie or whatever you
wrote but this isn't even this doesn't
happen anymore
a lot of comics aren't even doing this
[__] no more and to be honest with you
it's unacceptable
comedy club's not gonna allow that when
I got into comedy when I started
traveling 98
guys we had some [__] Savages on the
road you had and I'm not throwing
anybody under the bus everybody's aware
of these problems that we've all had you
had myself on the road doing [__]
Coke till you know it didn't end you had
the kid from The Living Color passing
out at different locations I mean
passing the [__] out he went missing a
couple times comedy clubs he would work
Friday and then they couldn't find them
till Sunday
what's his name
no it wasn't a way no the other guy the
little guy from the living Cub the
skinny black dude then great [__] guy
I'm not saying anything bad about him
I'm telling you a fact that when in 1998
99 there was some [__] people who
were you know they were like cousins to
Richard Pryor myself
Pablo Francisco was known for being
[__] wild Mitch Hedberg George Lopez
fell off a couple [__] stools people
don't remember they had to give him a
new kidney people don't remember this
[__] you know there was like six or
seven Comics that could die on the road
at any [__] time
every Monday you heard about a different
story whether it be myself and I wasn't
even headlining I was a feature at
causing [__] headaches for people but
you're talking about myself Pablo the
skinny kid from In Living Color he left
one night the skinny kid with Living
Color was in Miami and when he made the
biggest mistake of his life he got in
the car with Bobby Brown and Whitney
Houston that [__] was supposed
to get honored by the city of Miami the
next day never showed and he had three
sold out shows the next night he sold he
showed up at a quarter eight and they
couldn't find him all day he was foaming
from the mouth they had to give him like
10 cups of coffee and then they got on
stage and had a breakdown you know
[__] Mitch Hedberg [__] and I
don't know what year it was with a hotel
how to call the club and go you [__]
comic is walking in the hotel with [__]
running down his leg he had like a
diaper on and just [__] was running down
his leg bro we had some major league
[__] boozers and before then you had
the kennesons and the you know Lenny
Bruce is in the you know the stories are
endless when you're on the road you're
[__] getting down you know what I'm
saying well we're talking about green
rooms yeah now in today's [__] comedy
world
that's not acceptable guys
that's not acceptable I know a couple
comedy clubs that you're not allowed to
bring a [__] girl in The Green Room
unless you're married to her and [__]
like that I I've heard through different
things that people have tried to like
just bring like a friend like you know
you have a friend in Kentucky you're
flying to Kentucky the girl comes in the
owner's like I can't have a girl go into
the Green Room unless you sign a waiver
that's how [__] bad it's been out
there so for all you people that think
we're shooting everyone in the [__]
Green Room we're not hold on one second
now for a word
for my [__] sponsors all right
this episode is brought to you by better
help when you feel empowered you're more
prepared to take on everything life
throws at you therapy can get you to
that place when I was uh not doing well
when we moved I had anxiety I reached
out to better help and they were
tremendous Dana helped me she gave me
different little exercises to do and
writing assignments better help is the
therapy option that is convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist at any time for an
additional charge for no additional
charge it can be easier if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
Diaz again
betterhelp.com
Diaz today and I'm Gonna Get You ten
percent off your first month that's
better out dot com slash Diaz all right
we're back we're talking about [__]
green rooms the purpose of the Green
Room
isn't the party before the [__] show
starts I want to go down there
and I just want to be with me for one
[__] 10 minutes
you just drove there you got cut off you
got to find parking spot the [__] guy
didn't believe you were the comic he
didn't see your picture I mean there's a
thousand [__] things your wife is
pissed you got to take the wrong car you
had a flat there's so many things going
on in anybody's life never mind a
[__] Comics so when he walks into a
[__] gig
he just wants to go downstairs and relax
and the two other Comics that are
working with him it's understood
it's just a general thing that it's
understood
that hey
when we go down there we're going to be
polite we're going to tip the wait staff
you know if you order food or beer from
the wait staff you need to dip them not
you know like you're tipping some chick
at a bar but double because that's a
that's uh makes an impression of me like
[__] Joey brought people that didn't
tip no [__] tip and double
you know there's all these little things
when you go down there
that
I I just don't want you know there's a
TV I'll live with that but I don't want
you coming down I'm about to do comedy
what makes you think
I want to talk about your pet [__]
cat
what makes you think I want to talk
about your grandmother that's been in
the hospital for two weeks
we don't want to talk about any of that
[__] after this show I'll talk to you
about anything you want and even [__]
it and throw into the conversation
I'm all in with you but before the
[__] show I want to keep it light
what'd you have for breakfast eggs you
know [__] like that
I don't know what the [__] people are
talking about you know when I did these
Sony shows how we get them there'd be 20
people in The Green Room
smoking dope and jumping up and down I
go what the [__] is this
and I had to say to them a couple times
like guys
when we get in here come on man clear it
the [__] out you know I I had plenty
tickets a [__] show 10 tickets a
[__] show
it all depended on it whether they were
sold out or not and you know guys like
Mike would call me up and go hey man I'm
gonna come to the show tonight okay
I'll give you a ticket I mean I only got
10 shows and I would get a call back 10
minutes later can I bring four other
people oh and I wouldn't even get that
call back they just showed up that would
[__] eight people and then I had you
know this is the things that when you're
preparing for a show
you don't want to [__] deal with this
[__]
I don't want to deal with this [__] I
got a show to do in front of 500 a
thousand two thousand three thousand
people this is why my wife doesn't come
to these shows because I don't want to
worry about it's too cold in the green
room I don't give a [__] that's not my
problem dress warm [__] but I'm
not gonna be you know you give people
tickets and then then out of the show
they're calling you up I'm outside I
don't know what to I had a friend of
mine call me last night
in the [__] Green Room to ask me
where the bathroom was at the place
why are you [__] calling me I'm in
the [__] green room and you're
calling me from upstairs in your chair
to ask me if there's a bathroom in this
joint
and you're like
you know so all your enthusiasm like you
have you
I tell people all the time don't bet a
fighter when he's fighting at home
like if he's fighting in Memphis or I
don't know where the [__] he's from
Boston and he's making his home bet
against him
because he's getting tortured
you just get tortured
people just expect and they don't
understand that you're preparing
for a [__] the fight of your life
whether it's a comedy show whether it's
a fight whether whatever it's over like
I don't want to [__] hear from you
with dumb
[__] because I don't even know what
you're talking about I'm getting ready
for a show that's all I know
and if and as a [__] friend of mine
you should know that I'm getting ready
for a show oh well we're at the ticket
window and they won't let us say what do
you want me to do
what the [__] do you want me to do you
want me to get up go upstairs get pulled
by people people pulling my [__] neck
last Saturday night we had a situation
that my nephew is like I don't even know
how you do this
we get outside we get in the car we say
our goodbyes thank you good night we're
driving away and I hear [__]
what the [__] is that noise
like somebody chasing us I turn around I
mean Jay the driver was doing maybe 20
miles an hour down to that street you
know when you pull out of the theater
talk some girl 50 yards was running next
to the window
and I and I'm like I lowered the window
I'm like what are you doing and she's
like you got to stop I got to take a
picture I mean this chick was run then
she held on to the door and all I kept
thinking about was that scene and Almost
Famous well he's on the train and the
chick's like saying call your mother and
he's like okay and he keeps talking to
her and she runs and all of a sudden
there's a [__] beam and she runs into
it that's what I I told JJ stop she's
gonna [__] die this chick chased the
[__] car for 60 yards Full Speed
Ahead with heels on I had to stop take a
picture with her tell her I love this
she was going to be all right my nephew
called me goes what the [__] was that I
go dog how crazy are people getting
they're out of their fight listen all
that [__] is fun I love the people I run
into my whole point of this [__]
thing was I was talking about green
rooms and
what they're basically really for
that basically for the guy to go in
there or Whitney Cummings or Bert
Kreischer or whatever the [__] they are
or just a mumbo jumbo headline that's
getting his comedy career started to go
in there and unfold
for 10 minutes before the show
not have to deal with
anything like I don't want to deal with
anything like I I don't I really don't
give a [__] I don't have time to deal
with this right now
just you know and that's what the green
roomers for so if you're friends with a
comic a [__] musician
whatever the [__] you're friends with
this is what those things are for not
for you and your friends to go in there
before the [__] event or the fight
and wish him luck he don't need luck if
he needed [__] luck you know he don't
need your [__] wish or luck
just after the show go up to him and say
whatever the [__] you want but before
that he's got his mind on one [__]
thing performing playing singing playing
the drums whatever the [__] he does
that's it don't get offended if you
don't get the reception that you were
anticipating his mind is somewhere else
and it should be it's time for people to
start thinking about other people
like where's that mind at like when
somebody tells you go [__] yourself or
I'm busy or something you can't get mad
you have to stop for a second and go
where's his mind at what is going on
with his [__] world
where is he at at this [__] moment oh
I get it I didn't think about it like
that and I think that that's what's
going on a lot and that's what bothers
me a lot my main concern is
nobody has uh nobody considers your life
anymore it's what the [__] they're doing
and what the [__] they want to do from
short films to [__] you know rust or
whatever it's everything about what they
want to do and they never go whoa
what the [__] is going up with him I
forgot Joey has a 10 year old daughter
and the things that pissed me off the
most about when people invite me to
things that these are all people who are
parents
it's not like that I hang out with 20
year olds that don't know life These are
50 year old men and women that know the
position I'm in why the [__] are you
even telling me this [__] you got a
party coming up in a month
put the feeler out
send me the invite you know I don't have
babysitters I don't have all this [__] I
don't have family here you know my
friends up from [__] an hour away
they're not going to come down here and
babysit me because I want to go to a
restaurant or a party we don't have it
no more
so it's not that I don't want to go to
your Saturday thing you know I told you
[__] before I got here
I'd be mad at my friends like how the
[__] happened you've seen Mike
in nine months we used to hang out
together every day and you're like well
Mike Works days I work nights and I'm
like that's that's
[__] you know that's that's a
[__] [__] excuse but I didn't
realize how bad it was until I got here
because everything you're gonna do
it's you're gonna add two hours
two hours to to do something because of
the driving
you know how many days I got two hours
to throw away I don't
mean nights I I don't you know I've been
in [__] Jersey three years I I've
been in New York City 10 times five of
them were for this show two or three of
them were [__] auditions one was for
a Premiere it's not like I jump up and
down so it's not like I don't want to do
things it's that I'm smoking for if I
find the window I'll make it to your
[__] party if I find the window I'll
try to make it to your dinner you know
Saturday nights I was doing dinner with
my friends every other Saturday you know
every other month when we had time
and even them we had to stop because
everybody's doing living their own
[__] world so
think about what other people are
[__] going through as a matter of
fact I want to talk about the elephant
in the goddamn room
because I don't know what's going to
happen today I don't know what's going
to happen this morning
that tape got released Friday night from
that young man in uh Memphis guys I'm
not a political guy
I'm not going to tell you I know what's
going on in the world because I [__]
don't but I know people
you know I didn't even know it was
getting released Friday night to be
honest again we are so
you know I'm so over the [__] news
and I'm so involved with what I have
going on in front of me that my social
skills are [__] horrific I don't know
what's going on in the world socially
because let's face it the world is
[__] crazy right now you know you
wake up some days and you go what the
[__] am I even reading why the [__] is
this getting printed you know between
the [__] George Santos I don't know
what that idiot is doing or whatever
voted from should be shot hung and
[__] taken that voter card away
to Pamela and this insane Tim Allen's
[__] dick I had to put up with that
[__] last week and there's a video that
he did 20 years ago where he bent over
and he showed her dick you know every
week you ask yourself is this really the
world what is going on in the world
anymore that's what this podcast is
going to get called never mind the joint
it's that's what I should change it to
what is going on in the world anymore
you can just do an hour on some of this
[__] because nobody gives a [__]
remember I told you [__] that a
bunch of books that was going to start
coming out that they paid extra to
people to say stupid [__] remember I
told you [__] six months ago
that when I got my book they started
creeping around asking me stupid
questions I'm like listen guys I just
want to tell my story well isn't there
anything you I don't know nothing you
want me to be a crime stopper to sell
books on [__] that didn't happen if it
happened it was 20 [__] years ago
after all listen Pamela Anderson have
you seen Tim Allen's dick that the best
day of your [__] life because that's
the only normal dick you've seen Kid
Rock he [__] a thousand redneck chicks
with herpes his dick looks like a
hammerhead [__] shark we think Tommy
Lee's looks like well you all feeding
the [__] special and she's
complaining about this who would even
believe her who would like who gives a
[__] but that's the world we live in now
I actually saw people arguing about it
on [__] Twitter about Tom who's lying
who wasn't lying
if your life if anything was happening
in your life it wouldn't [__] matter
you know so but it's it's like every
week you wake up to something [__]
that you're like this this this has to
be a joke like this has to be a [__]
joke but guess what it [__] ain't but
what happened in [__] Memphis you
don't look
I could tell you I watched the tape and
you know I had to turn it off no first
off I seen this tape before in 1991 and
1992 with the guy in La the four [__]
cops beating up Rodney King in L.A we've
all seen this tape before this just
magnified to a different [__] level
what I can't believe is
and again this is what I have a hard
time with in life these days is
ow
with a magnifying glass on you
there's a magnifying glass on every
police officer as a matter of fact
there's a magnifying glass on each of us
right now
if you don't know that you [__] you
know
you know I was watching uh the Memphis
game I didn't even watch it I just
watched this thing that happened Memphis
was playing the Lakers
and Shannon sharp got into an argument
with one of the players
guys there was nothing even happened
and I counted I didn't even count I'm
just saying that a roughly estimate I
counted 2 000 people with cameras out
within two [__] seconds like it's on
automatic like instead of you know like
when people pulled the gun on you you
try to shoot them back no people got
their phones now on light speed like I
put mine on the hip it's quicker to
[__] you know be a crime stopper it
was hard to believe that all these
people
had their phones are taping the system
incident number one what's it got to do
with you
but we're living through a [__] phone
lens now you go to a concert everybody's
got that lens out taping everything you
the taping isn't unnecessary it's going
into your memory bank
if you have a [__] memory if I have a
[__] memory bank and I did all these
drugs and acid and pills you normal
[__] gotta have a [__]
memory bank I still remember Dave
Gilmore on top of that [__] Wall
playing Comfortably Numb I still
remember [__] uh Joe Perry busting
that [__] guitar on stage in 1977
before Ted Nugent we're talking [__]
40 years ago I still have those memories
etched in my [__] head you know and
you're gonna tell me you're gonna sit
there with a [__] camera taping come
on guys but it's right now everybody's
got a [__] magnifying glass on them
God forbid you do anything [__] wrong
you you tell somebody to mind that
business 20 people at the parking lot
have their [__] cameras out we're all
under a major Spotlight I'm not telling
you you cannot be you I'm not telling
you that I'm not telling you that you
have to walk around you know no you
always have to be you but with a
magnifying glass on you as a police
officer this is what you give us
this is not about black or white anymore
this is what it's got to do but a
handful of [__] just people who are
[__] psychos that are supposed to be
protecting us
so how are we supposed to feel
you know as an American now how are you
supposed to feel you got lied about you
know you got lied about you with your
[__] we were supposed to save you
from a [__] uh covid you got we got
life every [__] day every day we're
getting liked it and then when somebody
does raise their hand what do they say
all if they're doing our false
information no everybody's giving out
[__] lost information everybody's
giving it the [__] out so right now
we're faced with another [__]
Dynamite like the trust in this country
you know must be [__] I mean I have a
[__] uh a Christian Christian
father-in-law Christian father-in-law
Christian mother-in-law I've never slept
around them I worked my best never to
slip I respect them when he said that
covet was [__] I almost fell off my
this guy's never cursed in front of me
23 [__] years eve started going off
about this is the reason they told
people to take vaccines and to do this
to lie to I mean this is [__]
so now for this to happen on top of
everything that you know it's not a
white guy no more driving down the
street it's not a [__] black guy
driving down the street with two black
cows two white cops beating up on them
we don't know what the [__] is going on
anymore
you know we don't know what the [__] is
going on anymore so
my prayers go out to Tyree his family
for what happened a lot of people are
talking about this I'm not going to go
into this into that because I don't know
I wasn't there I'm just seeing what you
saw at the camera there must have been
more but whatever the [__] happened it
didn't justify
for what happened here on that and you
guys know I support blue I love the cops
man I got no problem with them this is
not call for me to debunk the police or
make things [__] worse
this just called yeah that well you
can't call for debunk the police
those are stupid [__] words right now
all we could do is try to make them
better I mean we gotta work a little
harder you know I listen I've been
arrested a thousand times I'm a walking
living breeding Criminal
I never ever had a cop touch me
because it was always yes sir no sir
and you know I left my ego at the door
so when I see this [__] even to me like
I know
a lot of people expect me to say some
[__] [__] about cops I can't I cannot
sit here because I've been done great
things from like cops have done great
things for me way before this [__]
if if cops didn't help me out when I was
younger we wouldn't be doing this
podcast I'd still be behind [__] bars
because they understood that you know
they listen to my story they look beyond
what the [__] was going on there you
know a cop's job a cop a guy that works
in a prison a probation officer all
these people get lied to
000 times a [__] debt I didn't
I didn't I don't know who did it it
wasn't me it wasn't my fault we all get
lights at 200 300 000 [__] times a
day especially in today's world you know
how do so when you approach a cop or you
talk to a cop if you're not talking to
him from the heart and from your hip and
from your [__] soul it's not gonna
work for you because they get so much
[__] thrown at him and again I'm not
sticking up for anybody here I saw the
tapes but I'm also a 60 year old man and
I know what goes on the streets
I tell you one thing that was not
justified it's never Justified but again
with those situations I don't know what
was going on
I don't know what was what happened the
moment before that
you know I don't know if those five cops
tried to get their dicks up from the
cops in [__] Nashville that chubby
little white chick and she said no and
now they're angry I'm just trying to add
some [__] humor to the situation
that's really humorous
what the [__] made those five six
because now they're going to press
charges on a white cop that nobody saw
you know yeah so it's uh It's just sad
man in other words don't get pulled over
that's what I tell people all the time
mind your [__] business
and uh yes sir and no sir they got the
[__] you know they got you guys and
with that that's it [__] it's
another
Monday morning [__] podcast
it's February that's it we gotta work
hard and work better we got a long
[__] year so we're gonna make this
[__] work I'm feeling good I'm
looking good what I'm gonna do now my
plan is to take uh
February
March
April promote the book do the audiobook
you know everybody talked me out of
doing the audio book that said it's a
pain in the ass
but you know what I love you
[__] I'm gonna do the [__]
audio book because I want to do it my
way I don't want to know Harvey [__]
homo reading my [__] book with like a
little [__] up voice so
you guys like P A lot of people read the
Tweets in my voice so [__] it I'm
excited for that that's gonna take time
guys so
I'm gonna take some time clear my head
get a little stronger see what I want to
do with comedy see what I want to do
with the rest of my [__] year
whatever
and uh I'm just really excited for the
book
this was a goal that I always wanted to
do so
I'm gonna give it 100 of my effort
and then in May I reevaluate the
situation see if I want to go back to
the Sony theater which I probably would
and maybe add a different one in Jersey
uh laughing gas should be in Jersey
by July in Atlantic City so we'll have a
new home in Atlantic City I'm very happy
about that laughing gas is doing some
great [__] things I mean uh
they got a blunt coming out and he
brought one of them Saturday night and
it was just [__] outstanding I love
all that [__] I used to like speedweed
uh Geno at speed we had a [__]
tremendous blunt for years and he would
bring me three or four of them every
Tuesday to The Comedy Store but
we moved Beyond The Comedy Store so now
we're here so I'm happy man I'm happy
things are going my way I completed the
residency it was five shows
I just wanted to see where it would take
me where I would go and how I would feel
and now I know what I'm thinking what I
need to do better what I don't need to
do and uh
hopefully we'll bring it back a lot
stronger guys and that's it that's all I
got for you today don't forget we had
Championship weekend Super Bowls in two
weeks and if you're running out of weed
why [__] around
go to
stonerclub.com
listen guys I got some edibles from them
the other day some true dose if you
don't eat those Trudeau's chocolate
you're [__] missing out you don't
need a lot of those they got some
[__] kick to them I got some edibles
for you Mike some laughing gas new
Edibles uh
that more Delta eight and stuff like
that but you know they do the trick I
got up in the middle of night to piss
Saturday night and I was [__] up Jack
he called me he's like have you feeling
anything you're doing that not that much
I gave it another hour when I woke up
when I got up in the middle night to pee
I was like
holy [__] I am [__] up I gotta get
back to bed before I pass out but anyway
stonerclub.com they got some great
[__] refund there they deliver in New
Jersey New York is open I don't know
what their uh schedule is in New York I
got you in New Jersey now it's nice it's
easy they're reliable they're safe they
deliver right to your door let you know
what time they're gonna be there and
they're just great people man it's easy
you don't have to [__] around stand
online like a [__] dunce at some
place fill out [__]
but that's it and that's that I love you
[__] with all my heart have a
great week welcome to [__]
February and I'll see you guys next
Sunday next Monday tip top [__]
Magoo stay black
all right I want to thank you Savages
again thank you for all the support
thank you for being here it's going to
be a great month February before we roll
This episode is sponsored by better help
when you feel empowered you're more
prepared to take on everything like
throws at you therapy can get you to
that place listen I was stuck two years
ago
I worked with Dana at better health for
about a year and I'll tell you I felt a
lot better took a few months she gave me
options and different things to do and
it was just great listen fill out a
brief questionnaire and we're going to
match you with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge better help is
therapy option that is convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz again visit betterhelp.com Diaz
want to get your 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
the freeze pipe if you tie the harsh
smoke and coughing attacks
it's time to upgrade to freeze pipe just
freeze it pack it and rip it it's just
like being in Aspen Colorado you have
the smoke passes through the Frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale the
bubbler that [__] can fit in
your pocket and they'll give you a bong
hit that your eye will fall out you
understand me freeze pipe is non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
Frozen a lot longer it cools down the
Smoke by hundreds of degrees and it's
even better now the 2023 Edition because
they've updated their bong so they have
six independent freezing calls for even
better airflow and much easier cleaning
experience so if you're sick and tired
of [__] coughing up a storm and you
want a nice beautiful bung
thefreeze pipe.com is for you pressing
code Diaz and save 10 on your first
order when you go to the freezepipe.com
again defreeze pipe.com pressing code
Diaz and save 10 off your first order
get yourself a bung a pipe or a bubbler
today that's the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Diaz to save 10 percent
the joint is also brought to you by
DraftKings NBA season is here and it's
in full effect right before the playoffs
right now DraftKings is offering no
sweat game time parlay every day for a
limited time new customers bet five
dollars and get two hundred and free
bets go to DraftKings Sportsbook app
today opt-in for the same game parlay on
NBA game if it doesn't hit you get a
free BET back who's better than
DraftKings nobody so download the app
today and sign up at code Joey
j-o-e-y new customers can bet five
dollars on the NBA and get 200 and free
bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NBA with Coach Joey
j-o-e-y minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details I want to thank DraftKings I
want to thank the freeze pipe and I want
to thank better hope for having our back
and having your back have a great day
have a great week and I'll see you
Savages next Monday morning
Tip Top Magoo stay black [__]
love you
[Music]